that's bringing you a bit of breaking
news it's an update in fact into British
Airways and flight cancellations you'll
remember uh yesterday that the airline
had canceled more than 50 departures and
more than 20 arrivals that was on
Thursday uh we were reporting that
yesterday well today at the airline
British Airways has also canceled 80
flights that includes both departures
and arrivals for reference just as a
comparison normally there are 600
flights in and out of Heathrow on a
normal day so it is still a considerable
number of flights canceled at the I.T
system back up and running we've been
reporting that and no flights are due to
be canceled tomorrow as things currently
stand we'll bring you more on that just
in case you are planning a getaway in
the next few days